[Music]
they taught me to tell you what you're
gonna learn today first and so that's
the first thing I'm gonna say and you're
gonna learn two things and if there's
two takeaways from today
besides how to be an awesome sre like
nori those two things are first is T oh
and a bunch of the other things we're
developing it at Google give you the
tools that you need to start s REM like
Google and saris and and second it's
working and second Dan's gonna tell you
all about what sto actually is you've
probably heard this word a lot this
conference and probably how many people
had never heard the word sto before they
came to Google cloud next a chunk of you
we're gonna make sure that you know what
that is but first of all who are we so
as I mentioned my name is nori I've been
at Google for 13 years in s3 410 of that
during my time in s3
I've worked basically exclusively on
infrastructure my first team at Google
my first SRE team at Google worked on
the infrastructure powering basically
all of the services that Google provides
all the DNS solves a load balancing das
protection stuff like that and in the
last two years I've been working on a
team that is responsible for the
infrastructure powering Google cloud my
team manages is responsible for the
production health of App Engine flexible
environment and gke and what I always
like to say about the teams I work on is
the y axis of our graphs is pretty nice
my name is Dan su Lee and I am a product
manager I've been at Google for about
five years and I've spent that entire
time working on Google's own api's and
services infrastructure the stuff that
serves the Maps API is the drive API is
the YouTube API is and of course all the
cloud api's and and for the last couple
years we've been focused on on
productizing that technology and that's
in the form of some commercial products
like Google Cloud endpoints and most
recently open source efforts like G are
PC and is do so as three as I'm sure
you're aware because you're here stands
for a site reliability engineering
and we call it site reliability
engineering this is the term that Google
made up because many years ago Google
was just a website these days it's a
little more than that but the term is
stuck around in the beginning when it
was just a group of software engineers
working on web search they set up our
learning a set up monitoring as I'm
gonna tell you all about in a few brief
slides and they sent their alerting
targets to page everyone all at the same
time when there was a problem and I
found that a few people were always the
same ones who were responding to alerts
and those people eventually sort of
gravitated into the role that became sre
and they what I liked about this role is
it's more of it's still operationally
driven we still get paged and we have to
fix the problems but it is edits at its
basis an engineering role so instead of
you know taking your classic ops role
from a generation ago where you get paid
to 2:00 in the morning you don't know
what's happening you have to fix the
proximate cause but that's about all you
could do in sre we do get paged ideally
not at 2:00 in the morning we have
pretty good to cite s3 team distribution
but you still you fix the proximate
cause you always mitigate first but then
you do a root cause analysis or a
blameless post-mortem you understand
what really happened what drove you to
this situation and then you it's not
only an option but it's in fact your job
to fix the problem so that the same
thing never happens again and that's why
I like it it's really got the the
balance of both of those s3 has learned
a lot during the last decade and in fact
more than a decade initially that was
how to run systems at scale power a
Google web search and then all of the
apps that run on the similar
infrastructure inside of Google but more
recently we've been learning how to
leverage that knowledge and bring it not
only to Google cloud but also into the
open source community this is a book
that our department sort of collectively
wrote it describes many sre best
practices and I'm on stage with Dan
right now because sto actually enables
you to implement many of these best
practices straight out of the box
by the way I don't know if any of you
have been in any sessions today that use
the dory
the dory is a QA tool that we use
internally at Google and as an
experiment we're letting you guys use it
here today so if you do come up with any
questions during the course of the talk
if you open up the next 18 app and go to
this session you'll see a little link
that says dory QA it lets you enter
question and it also lets you vote on
questions so it ensures that if there's
something everybody's dying to ask but
no one gets up to the microphone you can
upload questions so whether you're
submitting questions are just voting
please feel free to use that tool and
I'm also told to mention on that one
that we are able to go back after the
talk and respond to these questions that
we may not have gotten the chance to
answer during the session in the tool
you'll have to go back into the tool to
view that we can't send email
notifications but you'll be able to to
see some more answers there later so I
do want to start by talking about sto
what does this do and why is everybody
talking about it so much we're getting a
lot of n plus 1 redundancy here that's
apparently not jamming it just yeah
please do oh hey right now figure out
how to get to next slide maybe try the
other thing so is do is a service mesh
and and you're probably hearing this
term if you if you look at the Google
Trends on service mesh it is an area of
big interest and increasing interest and
and and I want to describe a service
mesh in a few number of words the
important things about a service mesh is
that it automates away a lot of the
things that we typically build on top of
our network stacks automates away things
like seeing what's going on in in terms
of traffic to your services providing
authentication and authorization on top
of those so it does that but very
importantly to be considered a service
mesh you have to do that in a
transparent way a service mesh isn't
something you code to necessarily in
fact most developers should never even
know it's there
it has to be something that that can
layer in on top of whatever you're
already doing whatever language you're
already using whatever platform you like
to deploy on the idea of a service mesh
is to automate a lot of the the
functionality out of the network up
level what the network gives you in a
completely transparent and
language-independent way and sto is not
just a service mesh but it's an open
services platform there are a few
different service meshes that have come
out in the last couple years and where
sto differentiates is by defining a set
of API s that make it easy to integrate
back-end systems as well so arbitrary
you log whatever you want to you monitor
wherever you want to you use whatever
arbitrary policy engines you want to and
again all your services are taking
advantage of that without without coding
themselves without without integrating
into the service mesh explicitly and
this we talk about it a lot in the in
the context of kubernetes but SEO is not
dependent on it's not dependent that you
only deploy workloads and kubernetes we
do have people who are deploying
workloads across VMs as well so what
does it do what is the functionality
that it offers you once you've layer in
this transparent service mesh the first
thing is observability it's kind of
unbelievable how many people out there
are deploying apps into kubernetes and
have no idea what's going on in those
applications it gives you good
visibility into what's happening in a
distributed application the second thing
it says operational agility and by
operational agility what I mean is being
able to control where a request goes and
be able to have a safe and sane way to
roll out new versions of services as
you're doing that and be able to control
hey maybe we need to send traffic to a
different region right now because this
one is is you know very busy or
overloaded and then the third major area
of functionality is security is allowing
you to secure traffic between services
and ensuring that now that your
application has gone from being a
monolith to being composed of say a
hundred separate services how do you
ensure that each of those is secure so
three big things for observer is do
observability agility and secure
how does it do that I won't go through
all the components but I will tell you
that the the key here is is through the
use of a sidecar proxy sidecar proxy is
simply a proxy gets deployed alongside
your application if you're doing this in
a in a VM you've got to make sure that
that proxy gets installed on the VM but
if you're using kubernetes kubernetes
has great features that allow that to
happen transparently so when you
whenever you deploy a pod you put
whatever you want in your containers
kubernetes can automatically deploy the
sidecar alongside your pod and
all traffic into and out of your service
goes through that goes through that
proxy and that means it can make smart
decisions about how to route that call
and we'll get into some details later
about what that means but also as a call
comes in can make decisions about
whether or not that call should be
allowed in and it and it does all that
again transparently your services can be
communicating via whatever protocol they
want HTTP for most of you G RPC for some
of you it could be just a TCP connection
it doesn't matter to us all the traffic
goes in and out and by interposing that
that's proxy in there we get to add in
some functionality this projects
something we started about 18 months ago
and we have been working with some
partners the whole time
IBM and lyft both started from the very
beginning with us we use lifts envoy
proxy super super performant small
footprint proxy that we really like and
is really getting great adoption across
the industry but we're also working with
a bunch of other pretty heavy hitters in
the industry Red Hat is is working on
this VMware has done a bunch of work on
it we're working with Cisco and so we're
really not we're really trying to get a
consortium of people from around the
industry to say hey this is a good way
to do this this is a good way to solve
this problem and we're getting as many
companies as we can behind him so the
first point Dan mentioned a couple
slides ago was observability so I'm
gonna give you a little background about
observability best practices and then
how we've implemented those at Google so
the first thing is observability begins
with monitoring now I admit that calling
monitoring an SRE best practice is good
of an exaggeration it's a very
fundamental brief story about this
so when Mikey Dickerson who's a former
Google essary went out to DC as part of
the tech surge to help fix
healthcare.gov a few years ago he found
that they had no monitoring well
correction they actually did have a very
basic form of monitoring it was a TV on
the wall and it was playing CNN and
whatever CNN reported this is no joke
whenever CNN reported that
healthcare.gov was down they knew they
had a problem they should probably go
fix it so anyone else used CNN as a
service they're the only ones also you
have to fix that Mikey
perhaps got a little exasperated and
drew them a hierarchy of needs he called
it a reliability hierarchy and this has
become known as the Dickerson hierarchy
of reliability since then modeled of
course after Maslow's hierarchy of needs
of physiological safety first and then
on up through friendship and things like
that in the Dickerson hierarchy of
reliability you have monitoring right at
the bottom because having CNN on the
wall is not an acceptable form of
monitoring and so in this pyramid that
I'm gonna show right now I've sort of
extrapolated monitoring out into its own
sort of pyramid with its sub building
blocks
what should you monitor at at Google in
the end over the course of developing
you know many best practices over the
years we've decided that we have at
least four golden signals and these are
four things that if you monitor or we'll
give you a really good basic insight
into how your system is doing and they
are in this order traffic how many
requests are coming into your system
this is commonly known as RPS requests
per second at Google we stall still call
them QPS and for most of our systems
because every request is web search
query right that sort of stuck around
but this is this is your building block
here is is how much traffic are you
serving beyond this as errors of that
traffic that you're serving are you
serving
successfully are you serving any of it
successfully are you serving all of it
successfully you need to be monitoring
not only the requests that come into
your system but also the percentage of
them that fail and I do mean percentage
you have to start with traffic so you
have a denominator here
but if you if you know that you have a
thousand errors per second that you're
serving that's probably a bad thing but
if a thousand requests per second or QPS
is actually Oh point zero zero one
percent of your overall traffic that
might be like an acceptable ish amount
of errors so this this is a rate here
the next one is latency
and we'll find that as we go up this
pyramid we're sort of moving out of the
realm of we need oxygen and we need
water and more into things like we need
friendship and latency is a really good
sort of friendship analogy in this
monitoring pyramid here latency is not
quite as fundamental as traffic and
errors but you still do need to be
monitoring latency to understand the
overall performance of your system users
expect apps to be superfast these days
and in this highly networked world's
most of that budget for latency is going
to come out of your code and so you do
want to be measuring latency an
interesting note on how to do this here
don't just do this as a straight average
latency if you took the average of all
the RO the latency of all of the
requests coming in to out of your system
you would end up alighting some
important points you wouldn't get a
sense of what the common experience of
your app is because you might have some
requests way out at your long tail which
for various reasons might be taking a
very long time to complete and these
could be for legitimate reasons or
reasons that you want to look into a
little more deeply but either way it's
really good to break that out and so
when we talk about monitoring latency at
Google we talk about it in terms of
generally three numbers we talk about
the 50th percentile or the median
latency we offer to that as P 50 and the
90th percentile P 90 and then P 99 as
well and taking those three lines as
separate you usually see them P 50 is is
pretty steady state for your system P 90
is probably generally a little higher
but but should still be within the realm
of normal
and p99 is a really interesting signal
to split out here so I think that's just
an important concept to mention that
latency as an average is not going to
get you very far and finally a
saturation this is a metric that is even
fuzzier and this one is up to you to
define a little more than the other
three saturation is the idea of at what
point is your service just gonna fall
over if you had no loadshedding no auto
scaling enabled nothing like that you
need to know about the the capacity of
your service so this could be as simple
as CPU utilization is a very common
saturation metric out of the box but it
also might be that based on your
knowledge of your own system it's
actually a much more complicated metric
that you calculate and that you can
export a variable based on this one but
what you want to do with saturation is
feed that into you know things I
mentioned such as auto scaling it can be
a signal to tell the system that is time
to auto scale up and and add more tasks
it can be a signal to load shedding to
say that the system is full we can't
auto scale anymore and we want to start
dropping queries it could just be a
white box signal to page human and say
please come back more jobs we're about
to fall over the system is almost at
capacity but no matter how you treat it
these saturation is the sort of forth of
these golden signals that taken together
form a pretty good idea of the health of
your overall system so in the old days
at Google whenever a new service wanted
to launch they would have to basically
write their own monitoring from scratch
I wasn't quite as dire is that I mean
there was a standard library each
service would include this standard
library and it export a standard set of
variables requests per second errors etc
but then the manual part was that each
new service owner had to manually
aggregate these and define the
monitoring configuration to aggregate
these all up and then define what were
the dashboards gonna look like it was a
very tedious process trust me I did it
once I've got the the badge to approve
it but I don't want to do it again and
so what's cool these days is that when
new service is launched or really when
you turn up any job in our production
environment
you get this for free these days now we
use a sidecar proxy and the sidecar
proxy is automatically collecting the
metrics that I mentioned is collecting
the golden signals and a fair number of
other ones besides and it automatically
puts these into a dashboard for you so
these days when we have this automatic
aggregation this is a screenshot of the
dashboard that you'll see we just picked
an arbitrary small service here but you
can see that these are three basic
graphs that just list out the golden
signals this no work was done on the
part of the service owner to get these
graphs this is observability for free
this has been an incredibly powerful
concept at Google not only does it
remove the need for each individual
service owner to redefine their
monitoring from scratch but it also
means that when you want to look into
the performance of somebody else's
system within our organization you can
do that and so in many cases again in
the old days we would maintain these
these lists of links to the various
monitoring dashboards these other
services and you hope that then you
remember to find where your page of
aggregated links is and that nobody else
move their dashboards with or not down
and it was a bit of a nightmare and
these days if you have a service that
has a dependency on some other service
you suspect the dependency may be at
fault in some issue you're currently
debugging you don't have to find your
bookmark link you can just go to our
central automatic monitoring dashboard
type in their service name and view
their dashboards it's so cool of course
these other services can go in and tweak
these metrics themselves they can make
custom dashboards they can make it
prettier but what you're seeing here is
that out of the box at Google
you just get dashboards for free I saw a
couple zoom in dashboards here this is
the top one you see this is requests and
errors there's three lines on here and
so you we actually almost always will
graph the requests per second against
errors per seconds there and two types
of errors in this one we also have the
internal error ratio this is the second
piece of that monitoring pyramid and
latency again you'll notice on the
latency graph there's those three lines
and the red one is p50 latency
pretty realm normal realm for that one
the next one up is p90 latency and
that's still within a normal realm you
can see in this particular graph it's
about double of what the p50 latency is
that may or may not be expected based on
the performance of your system but then
p99 latency
I think this perfectly illustrates why
it's really important to split these out
into their own bands so you can reason
about them separately the other part of
observe observability as a complement to
the metrics and the dashboards is
logging and debugging an issue
dashboards are a great start and often
they'll tell you what you need to know
sometimes you'll see a steep drop-off on
the number of running tasks or a steep
uptick and the number of queries per
second coming to your system those are
great places to start but occasionally
you'll get into a really gnarly issue
where you need to dig into exactly what
happened at a certain period of time at
Google our systems generate huge volume
of logs they're doing huge volume of
requests at all times
we basically log everything we have
reasonable retention periods but for a
finite period of time when you're trying
to understand what happened in your
system you can go back and and dig
through these logs to try to figure out
in precise detail what happened but the
only reason this works at all is that we
have tools to help us slice and dice
this data petabytes of logs are useless
if all you have is grep there was a
groan that's how I feel about that one
Dremel is our internal sql-like
interface over these huge volumes of
logs
it lets us drill down into what's
happening at the precise moment we need
it and it's a much more powerful tool
than simply trying to like open these up
in your editor and muck around to try to
distill down I have been at Google long
enough that it turns out that this
Dremel is such a power tool for me that
it took me many years more than I'd like
to admit of being an SRE before somebody
who pointed out to me that a dremel is a
real physical thing great so thank you
nori for that and and explaining what
what are these things that that we
feel you need to have the tools in your
arsenal that you need if you want to be
an SRE and and now I want to talk a
little bit about how sto gives you some
of those tools sure I can drive I
suppose didn't like me before again
emphasizing what I said about a service
mesh you can you can get observability
today all of you are doing someone and
no one is really using CNN right but
what tends to happen is different teams
solve this in different ways and if
you're running operations depending on
which team developed a service you might
have a different set of metrics some
things might be gathered from logs other
people are somehow sending telemetry
somewhere other things they would like
to use the same metrics that that team
has but they're developing in a
different language and the client
library just doesn't work as well a note
is it doesn't Java say so with sto we
want to give a standard set of metrics
without doing any integration without
language specific client libraries and
out-of-the-box we give you most of the
golden signals traffic errors and
latency the things that Nouri said you
can't really run a service well without
these metrics we give you that out of
the box so every service that you're
deploying into your service mesh you get
that out of the box now as she said
saturation is different for every
service in some cases it might be CPU in
some cases it might be RAM and some
other ones it might be a number of
operations going to disk you'll have to
figure that out for your service but for
most of these out-of-the-box will will
gather them and will send them to the
location of your choosing and to do that
we use a component in is Gio called
mixer mixer is a runtime component we
deploy into your kubernetes cluster and
it has a very pluggable architecture all
of these sidecar proxies when they
receive requests when they return
requests they are sending all the Salama
tree to mixer mixer then can plug into
the system of your choice maybe you're
using prometheus maybe you just run an
influx DB maybe you're you're using
external vendors people are writing
these already and certainly we have a
fantastic one for our stack driver tool
so mixer is the component that we won't
get into policy today but in addition to
action too
a enforcing policy it also gathers all
the telemetry and sends it out and of
course we think a great place to send
this is stat driver this is in alpha in
stackdriver today and it's a fantastic
view into not just what's going on with
a particular service but how these
services are interoperating this is a
dependency graph and it builds this
graph depending on the actual traffic
observed in your system this is a really
big deal when someone joins your team
tomorrow I guarantee you someone is
gonna go to a whiteboard and draw a
picture of what all your services are
and I can also guarantee it's probably
wrong I know this from when we got this
at Google people don't know their
dependencies they don't know who's
depending on them this actually knows
and it can tell you and it can tell you
not just how much traffic you're getting
but how much your traffic you're getting
from each client when things are running
slowly
this can help you route it out very
quickly and as you can see on the left
there you get the golden signals for
every one of these you get your traffic
you get your heirs and you get your
latency we collect all your logs too and
and I sometimes talk to customers and
they ask well what's what percentage of
our request should be logged the and the
answer is easy it's it's a triple digit
number you log all your requests you
don't have to keep them forever but when
something goes wrong you never know
which request was gonna make that thing
go wrong and if you weren't logging
you're in trouble but as Nora said lots
of logs are difficult to deal with and
almost unusable unless you have good
tools stack driver logs is it as I got a
great logs viewer but even better you
can pipe it into bigquery and in
bigquery
it's Dremel you can you can write great
sequel queries across those logs to do
analytics so you can figure out what
wrong went in a particular event and you
know big analytics things it's a really
really powerful tool I didn't get into
tracing but sto is also gathering
tracing for you as well now talk about
SLS so once you're monitoring your
service you can use these signals to
talk about health at the service level
and then also to help you plan how
you're going to react if those signals
start to dip a little bit there's lots
of TLA is in this space please bear with
me an SLI misses metrics essentially
this is basically the golden signals are
a great place to start they are just a
sense of what's happening in your system
and a quantifiable basis also I should
note that these are often the things
that you define your alerts on alerting
is it something I could give my its own
50-minute talked about but very briefly
if you alert on the golden signals
that's a great place to start a solo
uses the SLI these are targets for these
metrics or either target values or
target ranges
protip here a hundred percent is not a
good SLO typical availability ranges are
measured in a number of nines this is
again very service dependent it may be
two nines depending 99 percent depending
on what your service can reasonably
achieve or it might be five or six nines
a very highly available service but
again 100 percent is just never going to
happen
one of the fundamental tenets of
engineering for reliability is you have
to plan for failure things are going to
break machines are gonna break VMS are
gonna break the network is gonna go down
there will be failures and so assuming
or just hoping that they will never
happen is as we say in s re not a
strategy so set a really high service
service level objective but measure it
and nines and and don't use a hundred
percent here an SLA is a legal agreement
this is basically a threshold after
which the you the customer or your
customers depending on which direction
you're talking about get remuneration x'
or other other things coming back to
them in in breach of the contract so
when we're talking about reliability
from the engineering standpoint very
often internally we're speaking of SL is
an S ellos because those are the things
that we have the most direct control
over choosing what to measure and then
choosing what thresholds are actually
achievable and we leave SL A's to the
the more business and legal end of of
the company another way of saying SLO is
by instead of looking at the area under
that target thresholds looking at the
area above that's your Arab budget I
love this concept
um people can think of it and typically
do very productively as a constraint and
I think that's great I'll talk through
why I like that in a minute but I think
it's also important to remember the flip
side of that is that it can be
permissive as well so the constraint
side this is the typical way to think
about an era budget you set your SLO s
you monitor you define alerts you have
those alerts paging humans or or you
know maybe feeding back into automated
systems to take action and then you take
some sort of action at the system level
to increase reliability if you dip down
below your era budget again this could
be its own 50-minute talk but very
briefly a typical response to going out
of era budget is to freeze freezes are
basically the idea of you stop pushing
change live to your system change be in
the form of a new release candidate of
your binary or binaries or or even more
config we recognize that all of these
things are vectors of instability and so
you need to manage that instability
typically the way you do this is you
just stop pushing until you're back
within your era budget to recover that
and the idea here is twofold one it
gives your customers or your users a
greater period of stability because you
just experience an outage or maybe a
very slow trickle about it is and and
you'd like to have them have overall a
very good experience the other idea here
is that typically you can redirect the
engineering effort that would have been
going into new features into reliability
work the flip side of this is the way in
which an era budget is permissive as a
former manager of mine used to say well
good are all those nines if you can't
take them out for a spin every now and
then but I didn't say it jokingly and so
did he
but what I like about this is it
actually gives you a good sense of when
it is a good time to take extra risks in
is it's a good time right before your
big annual conference probably not but
if you're after week after if you are
well within your era budget and your
engineers have been asking to try out a
crazy new feature that is very well
tested but does carry a greater degree
of risk you have a budget to spend
that's why I like to think of it as a
budget
if you've ever been waiting for a new
feature from some Google product and it
seemed to get delayed maybe you know a
month later than you wanted it it may be
that that team ran out of budget and
they and they weren't permitted along
that launch that feature it really does
affect how we launch things so now I
want to talk a little bit about one of
the very cool things that isn't specific
to sto alone but is something that you
get when you combine sto and stackdriver
and that's the ability to define to
monitor your SL eyes and define s ellos
so I mentioned this before but we are
shipping today in open source an adapter
with SEO to send your metrics to
stackdriver
that includes your traces it includes
your your logs but of course the
telemetry the things that we're powering
that that graph I showed you before well
they've got a nifty new feature and
they're a nifty new feature is is the
ability to set service level objectives
and what's awesome is because they're
getting the the the metrics from your
services you can now set s loz service
level objectives on the golden signals
it seems like an obvious thing but it's
a fantastic thing I literally know
customers who alert because they have
their logs they scrape their logs they
send their logs to a third-party vendor
where they can write a grep run that
grep every say 5 or 15 minutes and then
if they have too many errors do an alert
who does something like that some of you
are not being completely truthful I know
that's happening it's a really really
great like you might as well turn on CNN
like this is the way you should be doing
this have something that's gathering
your telemetry set an issue to say hey I
want to make sure that we are available
that we're returning our requests
successfully say every week you might do
it per month you might do it per quarter
and say I want that to be at a you know
a certain range and 91 92 percent now
you set this objective within Google and
within stackdriver and stat driveable
will alert you if you if you get out of
compliance now you might not set this
where your SLA is if you're telling your
customers you know ninety nine point
nine you might say
this a little bit higher so that you get
alerted before your customer before
you're out of compliance but then they
will let you monitor this they'll show
you here's how you're doing against your
your goal and you can see sometimes I'm
above sometimes I'm below but what's
important they'll show you on your
budget as well in the aggregate are we
doing okay or are we not are we positive
or are we negative so it's it's a it's a
really fantastic tool it's taking some
very basic concepts if you've read the
sre book you will have read about this
and you made it thought wow era budgets
sound cool how would I implement that
the good news is that they just did and
that you can take advantage of this and
now back to you so another SR a best
practice is that a canary releases and
we do that so much we call it canary
Aang so as I mention when I was talking
about freezes new releases commonly
calls instability so you need to manage
that instability canary jobs are small
jobs that are basically identical to all
of the other workloads you have running
in production but they're configured to
get traffic early and they are also
importantly take a very small fraction
of your traffic and so the same concept
applies as the canary in the mine shaft
you send the canary down the mineshaft
first so that if toxic fumes have built
up down there the canary keels over
instead of all of the mining team all at
once same concept applies here if you
send a binary down into the mineshaft
this analogy is breaking down and it
falls over you know then to not
immediately continue your rollout to all
of production all at once creating a
huge outage a couple points about how to
do canary effectively one is you need to
monitor the canary because this is
remember running a very small percentage
of your traffic it might be 1% of your
traffic it might be even less than that
depending on your service you need to
monitor it independently if you just
fold it into the monitoring for your
overall service the error is coming for
even if the canary is loudly cheeping
and its death throes are going to get
folded in to the rest of your your
overall aggregate alerting and very
likely you won't hear about it so you
need specific alerting on your
canary tasks or your canary jobs and
they need to be causing somebody to take
an action either that's the automated
rollout server automatically rolls back
or human hits the pause button or
something but either way you need to
monitor these independently so that you
can catch things early which is the
whole point and the other thing is going
to pace yourself your service may go
through peaks and valleys in web search
back in the day probably still they we
had a nice diurnal curve and your
service may be may have different
traffic characteristics also depending
on the deployment of your service the
various locations may have received a
different traffic mix and so you ideally
want to have canary jobs in each region
or in each place or each configuration
that has a unique percent of perspective
on your service just to get the best
signal you can and so you want to go
slowly here whatever that means for your
service in the case of something like
web search you might choose to do a
one-day canary period just to get the
full diurnal cycle and make sure that
your canary really sees all kinds of
traffic in something where you have a
much more aggressive CIC dianna like
every half hour basis the canary may
only be thirty seconds or a minute or
something but this is something that
you're going to want to define to be
meaningfully slow for your service
guess what sto helps with that too so I
want to start by talking about the
problem with kubernetes and and by the
way Inori did say Dan are you sure you
want to title a slide the problem with
kubernetes and I laughed and I said yes
someone else are you sure you don't want
to just call it a problem with
kubernetes because there might be more
than one but one problem with kubernetes
is that kubernetes load balances if you
if you've got a workload that's running
at enough scale that you need two pods
it'll load balance between those two
pods so if you you know version one
you're you're doing enough QPS then it
takes two to satisfy that it'll run two
well say you've got a new version of
that binary that you deploy what does
kubernetes gonna do a little it'll bring
up a new version of that pod and it will
get an equal share of the traffic this
is not a best practice in kubernetes if
you need a 1% rollout you shouldn't need
to run 99
of your other thing in order to achieve
that 1% rollout but that's literally
what you would have to do and I've heard
vendors talk about things just like that
that's not the right way to do things
and she said you want to start with
something small 1% for us sometimes it's
a tenth of a percent and then you want
to go to say 10 and then you want to go
to 20 or 50 right but you want to
control the pace of the rollout not with
the number of pods that are running but
with something a little bit more
explicit so we have a component called
pilot and pilot is a component that
pushes route rules to the sidecar
proxies and and what this gives us is
the ability to do load balancing but
importantly it enables us by the way
this is also running an ingress so for
traffic coming from you know if the
internet it's also going through an
envoy proxy and pilot can tell your
services whether they're the ingress or
whether it's service to service traffic
hey there's a new version of this one
but you should only send one percent of
the traffic to that so it's it's easy
it's a gamble and here you see has got
some Yambol that shows we've got v1 I
want that to get a weight of 90 and I've
got a v2 and I want that to get a weight
of 10 so in in kubernetes it's still
running three pods but they're not
getting equal shares instead that that
version two is getting the 10% you want
and of course we are gathering the
metrics from it we're gathering that
Slama tree so we can actually do the
thing that you really want which is you
can look at your telemetry for just that
canary and you can say is this in is it
compliant or the error ratio is where we
expect them to be or the latency is
where they expect to be and if so then
we'll go to that next phase so getting
started with this Gio we'd love for you
to get started with this Gio as I said
we've been going at it about 18 months
we are very very close to declaring it
1.0 that'll happen
any day now we've done a lot of work
this is not a half-baked project we have
over 200 developers have contributed to
the project we're very happy about that
from a bunch of different companies as I
said we've got it in production eBay was
it was on stage I think talking about it
and sitting in the front row here we
have a few different customers auto
trader in the UK we've got people who
are doing hundreds of thousands of
requests a second we have people who are
doing more than a thousand services
these are all production use cases I'm
talking about
we've got adaptors for many monitoring
systems including of course stackdriver
and what's what we announced what was
announced on stage yesterday was managed
SEO as part of our coming cloud services
platform we are just about to go into
alpha on managed sto and that's sto
automatically installed upgraded and
supported in gke so you can get started
soon
you
[Music]